now that you've added the URI
information to the weather contract step
two of building our content provider
I've got some explaining to do at the
beginning of our weather contract you
can see we defined the content authority
next we added strings for the base pass
for our URIs note how these paths match
our two tables for each of our tables
location entry and weather entry we
created a content URI that represents
the base location for each table
something else that is convenient to
have in the contract are functions to
help build the content provider queries
now for some URI builders in decoder
functions or whether entry it's
convenient to have these as it makes
fewer places in your code aware of the
actual URI encoding keeping this
knowledge in the contract strings such
as the location setting can be appended
with the append path function you'll be
implementing the build weather location
function shortly in this case adding an
additional path to the URI does not
change the type of the URI see they're
both type der we can also use these
functions to add potentially useful
query parameters in this case we use a
query parameter for the start date query
parameters are useful one for when we
have a fixed database query that we want
to have some limited parameterization
for in this case it will be a parameter
for our join between the two tables more
on that later URI queries look just like
the queries you see in web URLs and give
us the ability to add more richness and
complexity to our URI contract finally
we have this function that builds a
two-part URI with both weather and date
segments below this we have helper
functions that hide the URI structure
from our code for retrieving values from
the URI and place all this knowledge in
one place looking back at our list of
you our eyes you can see that for each
URI I called out whether the URI
returned a list of items by labeling it
with der for directory or a single item
by labeling it with item cursors
returned from a content provider have
unique types based upon their content
and the base path used for the query
Android uses a form similar to the
internet media type or mime type to
describe the type
by the URI cursors that can return more
than one item are prefixed by the cursor
derp based tight string while cursors
that return only a single item are
prefixed by the cursor item based type
string we define these types here for
both the location and the weather
queries